i'm ashley webster i'm kennedy i'm jason
chaffetz and this is the fox news
rundown
friday september 3rd 2021 i'm lisa brady
one week from tomorrow the nation will
mark 20 years since the 9 11 attacks a
new documentary opens a different window
to that day it's called the lost calls
of 9 11. they were all there
they were just across the street so they
had a way out
and i i think toward the end of the show
it gets
very deep and very personal but what
they saw and what they heard is
something they cannot erase we speak
with the host fox's bill hemmer
i'm chris foster anyone helping women
get an abortion in texas can now be sued
for ten thousand dollars and there could
be more restrictions approved by the
supreme court down the road abortion is
still protected under roe v wade you
could you could certainly see this this
court which is now what six to three
conservative voting to you know maybe
not to repeal roe v wade but certainly
to cut away at it and and cut away at
the productions in the first trimester
we speak with fox news sunday host chris
wallace and i'm kt mcfarland i've got
the final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's almost time for the bells to toll
and the names to be read to honor the
dead and the heroes from september 11th
2001. i saw people running on fire
through the streets
i saw people dying together people are
dying out of the world
what you're hearing now is something
that hasn't been heard before recorded
phone calls on a trading floor across
the street from the world trade center
fox's bill hemmer explains what they are
and how they were found in the lost
calls of 9 11 which airs sunday for the
first time on fox news channel in this
new documentary that we're putting out
one thing that caught my eye
there's a newspaper headline from the
new york times and to paraphrase it says
president bush tells the military to get
ready
so that that was the beginning for the
war on terror
that was the beginning
of our
original footprint in afghanistan
hemer is co-anchor of america's newsroom
and also host of the hammertime podcast
now with the events of this past week
and the suicide bombing that took 13 of
our service men and women i i think it's
more profound than ever because yes
we'll be thinking about the last 20
years
as we think about the last 20 days
that's where the conversation's going to
be
do you think that this year's
solemn ceremonies this time marking 20
years since the 9 11 attacks will be
overshadowed at all by what has just
happened in afghanistan yeah i guess my
my feeling is that
we're going to ask ourselves what did we
get from it or what did we get out of it
and how much better are we or how much
better are they
and i i i think you're going to hear a
lot
of varying opinions
on how people choose to answer that
whether they're in the military or
ex-military whether they're in
government or ex-government whether
they're in the media people like me who
have covered many of these events for
the past 20 years all this is going to
be mixed into the conversation that we
as a country will have this coming week
always with the thought in mind that
what the service members have done at
all you know levels of the military is
certainly worthwhile no matter what
anyone's position is you know sort of on
the outcome in afghanistan but that it's
it's kind of a difficult line that's
being walked right now because of of the
overall debate yeah i think you know the
political leadership makes decisions and
they tell the military what to do and
the military goes in and completes the
mission that's that's their job and
i think when they were
literally asked to evacuate a country
with just a couple days notice it
appeared
that they got the job done and they got
a lot of people out but not nearly as
many as we needed to
but that wasn't their decision those
were decisions that were made by
politicians
i know you and your co-anchor dana
perino have interviewed many people from
all angles of the afghanistan story
veterans lawmakers afghans
if you had to sum all of it up
everything you've heard in those
interviews for the past few weeks
what would you tell me wow um i
i personally have found it to be a very
emotional two and a half three weeks
um
dana and i were on the air speaking with
this gentleman that will call by the
name of carl who's still trying to get
out of the country in fact
and he was there for the bombing at the
the abbey gate and he described a
five-year-old girl who just died in his
arms and he described us military
members who had been at that time
wounded that he saw
later the news got worse
you know when you hear that in real time
and you think damn it we were so close
so close to getting out
and so many families had to suffer on
the way out
i just i just found it to be filled with
emotion
and i can only imagine next friday
september 10th
and next saturday september 11th will be
similar
one of the things that kind of hits me
with each passing year after 9 11 is
that there's always something new a new
perspective from someone's experience
and that is what your special that first
airs over the weekend is going to tap
into the lost calls of 9 11.
what are these lost
calls good question
i think many of the stories we hear from
year to year they're very personal and
they deserve to be told but this is a
story that has yet to be told
the trading floors for different
financial firms
they have phone recording machines
because they want to make sure that you
know clients when they call or traders
when they call uh to place a trade that
they don't miss it well this machine was
running across the street from the world
trade center
and although there was significant
damage done to the building
the recording machine actually survived
but
in the process of reopening the business
in the offices they had moved all the
office equipment out of there basically
to a warehouse in texas
and believe it or not over the past 20
years there's a guy who's living in
texas his name is rick harold he does
this kind of as a hobby and he bought
this machine for three hundred dollars
and he went home and he started
listening to it and he says in our
special he knew exactly what it was
and then he had to figure out how to
literally splice the audio tape together
so that he could complete the
conversations that were recorded on this
machine and there are many conversations
the amazing thing to me is that all of
these people
on that machine are still alive and the
story was go out and find them
and let them hear it for the first time
20 years later that's wow
wow that is
chilling
what surprises you
the most about these calls or what
stands out to you the most um i i think
just the personal nature of them is what
strikes me
they were all there
they were just across the street so they
had a way out
and i i think toward the end of the show
it gets
very deep and very personal but what
they saw and what they heard is
something they cannot erase
wow
and i mean i'm wondering if it seemed
like
anyone had any idea who was responsible
or the gravity
of what had happened and i asked that
partly because
after the attacks especially in new york
where the trade center had already been
attacked in 1993 u.s officials certainly
had ideas about who would have done it
but i remember it didn't feel at the
time
as though al qaeda or the taliban were
common knowledge in america did it yeah
there was
from my memory only one person publicly
who called it out in real time
and that was john scott here at fox news
john was very familiar with the
terrorist network the terrorist
operation he had been involved in the
1993
attempt that was partially successful
for the world trade center and so john
was pretty keen into what osama bin
laden was all about and he made the call
live on the air this this must be the
work of al qaeda i believe is the phrase
he used
he was one of i would say only two
people in the first 15 to 30 minutes of
september 11 2001 who had suggested that
no one in our special said oh this is
the work of al-qaeda but some of them
had been there in 1993 for the first
bombing so they were suspicious but
nobody brought it up
i personally was waking up in atlanta
georgia that morning i was working for
cnn i had done a late show the night
before the 10 p.m newscast and
our lead story was will michael jordan
come back to the nba
will he come out of retirement and we
were hustling and at least we were
getting people on the phone and we felt
really good about what we produced
but we woke up the next morning to a
whole different world and i remember at
8 45 my phone rang and i did not answer
it and my recorder went on
at my townhouse in atlanta and it was my
mother and she said billy are you up
turn on the tv
dear lord i think we're under attack
i wonder now that we're
this many years out um
are we
doing enough
to
you know because with each passing year
there's more people who weren't alive
when this happened or were too young to
remember so it's like
are we doing enough
and doing it in the right way to teach
the younger generations about what
happened what do you think great
question um i i think um part of that is
on them and part of it's on us and we do
it together right
that's how you reach an education
my biggest fear
whether it's al qaeda or whether it's
isis k or whether it's the akani network
all of these groups in my view have a
new place
for which they can go and find their
secret private refuge
and what concerns me about that is i i
think it was two years ago isis in
i think in the arabian peninsula is the
name of the group that was going by that
this is sinai egypt and they were able
to take an explosive device and put it
in the size of a soda can and attach it
to the back of it an airplane commercial
airplane and it blew up the engine and
pawn take off and
the plane fell from the sky and
everybody died
so
if they were able to do that in a camp
somewhere in sinai egypt or yemen or
just across the the red sea
you know what what can you do when you
have complete run of the place at a
terror camp in afghanistan
well we we understand what osama bin
laden did southeast of kandahar at
tarnik farms
he was there for several years and they
plotted and they planned and they
eventually carried out one of the most
devastating attacks anyone will ever see
in their lifetime
and my great concern is that isis has a
new home
or al qaeda has a new home and they will
have free reign
to be as devious as their minds can
possibly be and that's what we have to
teach the younger generation and that's
what we must take
great care in paying attention to from
this day forward
what do you hope people will take away
from the lost calls of 9 11. well
there's a father here who calls his
daughters
from downtown to let them know that he's
okay
and i i
i bring that up to you because what
you'll see is you know the relationship
that he had with them and they had with
him and what's happened to all three
since
but just the the simple act
of a phone call to let loved ones know
that you're okay
it's significant certainly during the
attacks of 9 11. but you and i we do it
every day friends and family members
send a text or make a phone call
to let them know that we're okay and we
want to hear that in in return
and i think it's one of the more simple
things we do in life
um
but the fact that so many did it
at that moment to take care of their
family and friends is what really
really strikes me
very special the lost calls of 911 airs
this sunday on fox news channel and then
it will be streaming on fox nation and
fox's bill hammer thank you very very
much for your time great to be with you
thanks for your time and i hope you
check it out
[Music]
this is kt mcfarland with your fox news
commentary coming up
wednesday a law took effect in texas
essentially banning most abortions by
allowing private citizens to sue anyone
who helps a woman get one after six
weeks of pregnancy the supreme court
allowed it to happen by letting a lower
court ruling stand issuing a decision
five justices to four to let the law
stay on the books pending legal
challenges it brought pro-choice
protesters to the state capitol in
austin
[Applause]
president biden attorney general merrick
garwin say they're exploring legal
options to protect abortion rights in
texas governor greg abbott on twitter
writes texas will always defend the
right to life clearly the pro-choice
people suffered a big setback this week
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday the supreme court has at least
temporarily
allowed a texas law to stand which says
that abortions are illegal
after six weeks now they were very
clever in texas because instead of this
having to be
enforced by the attorney general
basically the enforcement is left up to
citizens you know that if you
think that somebody has cooperated an
abortion not the woman who gets it but a
doctor
a cab driver driving somebody to the
abortion clinic you can
file a civil suit
against that person and if you win you
get your legal costs back and you get
ten thousand dollars so the result is
that when it went up to the court for a
preliminary injunction you don't enjoy i
didn't realize this until this week you
don't enjoin the law you enjoin an
individual normally would be like the
attorney general of the state but the
attorney general isn't enforcing those
citizens are and it hasn't been enforced
yet so this was purposely done as a way
to make it impossible or make it harder
it's really what i should say to stop
the law block the law so there'll be a
court case on this at some point but
right now abortions are illegal in in
texas
after six weeks which is just according
to statistics long before a lot of women
even know they're pregnant yeah because
i mean that of those six weeks two of
them are you know could be before you
could possibly know you're pregnant
beyond the cleverness of it the legal
cleverness of it i wonder how messy this
could be if it took effect now let's say
your neighbor who you didn't like very
much was pregnant
had a miscarriage wasn't pregnant
anymore
who's to say you can't just sue somebody
for ten thousand dollars uh i mean
there's a chance this could clog the
courts i don't know what the standard's
gonna be
well i i don't i don't think we do know
this is really a novel period it's the
first time it's been done
where it you know instead of a local d.a
or the attorney general of the state or
somebody enforcing the law it's really
put into the hands of john q citizen and
it's not a criminal offense it's a civil
offense so you're right i mean you know
there is the possibility of all kinds of
stuff
clearly and the court is going to hear a
mississippi law which doesn't have all
of these legal exceptions but just makes
it a lot earlier i think it's 15 weeks
that that you can ban an abortion and
viability is generally considered
between 22 and 24 weeks and that's
basically the standard now the courts
have said
pre-viability when a fetus could live
outside of the mother abortion is still
protected under roe v wade you could you
could certainly see this this court
which is now what six to three
conservative voting to you know maybe
not to repeal roe v wade but certainly
to cut away at it and and cut away at
the productions in the first trimester
yeah it was that mississippi case that
people were really looking at just
suddenly texas popped up it's strikingly
how quietly and seemingly quickly this
happened maybe not if you were really
following it in the courts or in texas
knowing the law was supposed to take
effect wednesday but suddenly here we
are
yeah i the only point i guess i would
make is you know oftentimes the courts
decide things not on the
constitutionality of the law but the
technicalities and issues of standing
and things like that sometimes you know
one side wins or loses on on that kind
of an issue for instance when the trump
electoral issues came to the supreme
court they were rejected not on the
merits of the trump election and whether
or not they've been fraud it was a
question of standing remember when the
texas attorney general sued for what was
happening in pennsylvania and the courts
threw it out just on that basis so the
texas case yes it now stands and that's
the law in texas but they have not and
they very expressly said they have not
ruled on the constitutionality of that
the mississippi will be the first case
where they rule on that
yeah i mean beyond being mad at texas
republicans a lot of liberals are
retroactively angry again with justice
ruth bader ginsburg for not retiring in
2013 and letting president obama replace
her with somebody younger when he when
he could maybe hillary clinton could
have done a better job in 2020 making
the supreme court a campaign issue
liberals are bringing senator susan
collins when during the brett kavanaugh
supreme court confirmation hearing she
said no i believe that he's going to
stick with president so
uh
a lot of liberals are looking at
or looking at the blame to go around
yeah and interestingly enough i did an
interview with stephen breyer for a new
book he has out and it's it the
interview will be sunday the 12th and i
talk to him a lot about retirement
because the court is now six to three
republican appointed generally
conservative justices versus three
democratic more liberal justices and
there's been a lot of pressure
especially after ruth bader ginsburg on
briar who's now 83 years old retire
you hear people like amy klobuchar or
alexandria ocasio-cortez saying this
because you've got a democratic
president and you've got a democratic
senate which would have to do any
confirmation and people remember what
what mitch mcconnell did with merrick
garland so retire now but he didn't in
june and he's going to serve this whole
next term
and he's under a lot of pressure so i
ask him about his decision and he'll
have that's called a tease you'll have
to wait and see a week from sunday what
he has to say about it well in the
senate let's say california governor
gavin newsom loses this recall election
coming up
and then so republicans in charge and
then let's say something happens
to a senator in california who then gets
replaced by a republican and now the
republicans control the senate it's too
late for the supreme court
well
yes and no i mean
mcconnell has not said i'm going to
block it i think it would be very hard
for him you know he did block merrick
garland but it was only eight months
till the election that was a choice of
barack obama you know if let's say this
were to happen and you get a republican
senator or you know there are a variety
of things in any state where there's a
republican governor if a democratic
senator were to pass away
then you're going to have a republican
replacement and mitch mcconnell instead
of being the minority leader becomes the
majority leader but i don't know that he
can block a biden appointment for two
plus years you know eight months was
controversial enough i don't think he
could do it if all this were to happen
in 2022 but this is the reason
democratic uh you know and liberals are
so upset because they see you know
instead of it being six to three it
could be seven to two but you know
incidentally the flip side could happen
obviously there are some older
republican justices one of them could
retire or pass away although i don't
think any of them are going to retire
while biden as president
and then you know the democrats could
flip one of those seats too
it's one of the reasons interestingly
enough breyer his whole book is called
the authority of court and the peril of
politics and what he says it's very
interesting
he quotes alexander hamilton who said
that the supreme court has neither
pursed the power of money like the
congress or sword the power of
enforcement like the president so what
it really relies on for its authority is
public acceptance and things like and
it's happened both ways the senate
playing games with the confirmation of
presidents of nominees is one of the
reasons it cuts against the authority of
the supreme court
let's talk about afghanistan for a
minute president biden the other day was
for lack of a better word defiant about
his decision to stick with this deadline
to pull troops out there are still
american citizens there who want to
leave
some of them have roots there wanted to
stay or some of them are babies who were
brought back there but there are
americans and certainly who knows how
many afghan allies who want to leave
and there are republicans who say the
president should be impeached over this
well i mean myself i think the
impeachment is is crazy you know if
we're going to start impeaching people
for judgment calls they make about
policy remember you can argue about the
execution of this but you know donald
trump wanted to get out and in fact
negotiated a deal with the taliban and
mike pompeo was the first american
secretary of state to actually meet with
the taliban so you know i didn't hear
any republicans calling for impeachment
then
i certainly think he's going to pay
a heavy political price and my own
opinion i think he should pay heavy
political price i think the evacuation
was a mess you know there were tens of
thousands
you know 100 or so
americans but tens of thousands of
afghans who stood up with us
during the 20 years as translators as
drivers as cooks you know whose lives
are very much in danger and they're
still stuck in the country and it just
seems to me we did it backwards that
instead of withdrawing our troops first
and then worrying about the equipment
and the civilians we should have gotten
the civilians out and then the equipment
and then the troops we did it exactly
backwards and the result is you know the
the the line is leave no no man behind
that's sort of the american military
credo we got all of our troops out but
we left a lot of americans and a lot of
our allies stuck in a taliban ruled
afghanistan
of course we were in afghanistan for
almost 20 years because of the 9 11
attack 20 years ago now you have a new
book out next tuesday september 7th
called countdown bin laden about the
hunt to find and take bin laden out yeah
you know i think chris that this is a
particularly timely book now i certainly
didn't write it expecting the taliban to
be back in control but as bad as we feel
and and i can understand why all
americans would feel badly about leaving
americans behind that the fact that on 9
11 2021 the taliban will be in charge
just as it was on 9 11
2001 but we did accomplish some very
important things in our 20 years there
one was we got bin laden and degraded al
qaeda and the other is that it was such
a flawless mission that the intel
community and the military and the
political community work together
so flawlessly to bring this off
as badly as i think they did to bring
off the evacuation and this book is like
my previous book countdown 1945 about
the atomic bomb on hiroshima it's a day
by day account of you know it starts the
day that the operatives and the cia go
to see leon panetta who's the cia
director and say hey we have found this
compound in a badabad pakistan and it's
the best lead we've had on bin laden's
whereabouts in 10 years and then through
the meetings of the sit room and then
the military planning and then in the
helicopter and the way to a badabod and
then with the seal
rob o'neal as he climbs up the stairs in
the main house and ends up face to face
with bin laden
and you know there's a lot to be proud
of there and it's a hell of a story and
i promise you although we all know how
it turns out those last hundred pages
you're going to be on the edge of your
seat because it's pretty damned exciting
your book about the nuclear bombing uh
japan that was really a page turtle so
i'm really looking forward to this one
too
well thank you and and let me just say
two things that i think a lot of people
may not know one is when he was in the
sit room and after he heard from
everybody and joe biden incidentally was
against the raid to bring down bin laden
he and the defense secretary gates obama
said you know for all of the back and
forth he said it's basically a 50-50
proposition and no better than that
whether or not bin laden is even there
and the other thing which i really
didn't know until i started interviewing
two of the seals
they thought this was a suicide mission
they thought there's no chance we're
coming back from this alive the
compound's going to be booby-trapped
they're going to be bodyguards there you
know we maybe we get bin laden but
they're going to get us and they still
went ahead with it it's
all i can say is it's a hell of a story
wallace host of fox news sunday author
of the upcoming book countdown bin laden
chris good to talk to you thanks
thank you chris
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at
guybensonshow.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now
some good news with tanya j powers
[Music]
wedding surprises come in all forms but
one that happened last month was life
changing
just minutes before dontez williams tied
the knot with michelle leberton he made
a proposal of a different sort he gave
heartwarming vows to abigail and natalie
michelle's young daughters asking them
if they'd accept his wish of becoming
their legal father he told fox news he
felt it was important to include them in
their wedding ceremony because he's been
there in their lives for seven years
abigail is nine and natalie is eight and
dontez first met them when they were
very small when dantes started his
proposal the girls initially looked
confused because he hadn't done this at
the rehearsal
then they quickly caught on to what was
happening and the tears started
dantes had kept the whole thing a secret
from everyone even michela who was
surprised but happy the two got engaged
in 2017 originally planning their
wedding for 2020 but the pandemic pushed
it back a year as for the moment when he
asked the girls if he could be their
father dantes describes it as priceless
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
kt mcfarland
what's on your mind tuesday president
joe biden made the most important speech
of his presidency americans in the world
watched as he threw away his one chance
to rise above his tragic withdrawal from
afghanistan and bring americans together
after 20 years of war
no one expected him to be winston
churchill rallying the british after
dunkirk nor abraham lincoln consoling
the nation after the slaughter at
gettysburg nor did anyone expect
something like ronald reagan's eulogy at
the tomb of the unknown soldier a decade
after the tragic vietnam war but he
could have at least been straight with
us
instead of speaking to a nation in pain
president biden made this speech all
about himself he dodged and weaved and
blamed others and even claimed our
evacuation from afghanistan was a great
success while most everyone saw it as an
unmitigated disaster
he should have left that kind of speech
for another time and place there will be
investigations finger-pointing and
recriminations in the days ahead
hopefully those responsible for how the
administration ended the last 20 years
of american involvement in afghanistan
will be held responsible and made to
account for their actions but on this
day we needed our president to rise
above the petty politics of washington's
swamp and speak directly to the men and
women who fought and bled in afghanistan
and to the gold star families whose
loved ones gave their lives and to the
world bracing for what will come next in
afghanistan and the region
we needed him to reassure us that their
sacrifices were not in vain
the failures in afghanistan were not of
their making but due to the deliberate
and inadvertent mistakes of our senior
military and political leaders
we needed president biden to admit
defeat we failed to build a modern
democracy in afghanistan and despite our
efforts we failed to destroy islamic
extremism or even al-qaeda's heirs
we needed him to rise to the power and
majesty of his office and confer on our
men and women the blessing of a grateful
nation
he did not
president biden may not have intended to
but his remarks personified the failures
of 20 years of the war in afghanistan
our leaders made mistakes that cost
people their lives but those leaders
were never held accountable they were
never straight with us they cared more
about their legacies their reputations
and their personal popularity than they
cared about the american people
the men and women who served in
afghanistan deserved better than this so
did the american people
may the good lord
bless the sacrifices of our men and
women who fought
bled and died in afghanistan because our
president did not
i am kt mcfarland i was president
trump's first deputy national security
advisor
and i'm the author of the book
revolution
trump washington and we the people
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
hey it's fred larson inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars it's an
idea that seems a lot like kickstarter
called build it subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes